deedy what made you think okay we've got
this like super complex story we're
gonna finally make everyone understand
why the bank's collapsed and what
happened we need the guy behind Ron Ron
Burgundy as our director honestly when
Adam called us and said can I do this we
were like oh thank god we're so stupid
we never would have cracked this that's
the truth we had a really good script
but it it was remaining elusive and we
tend to be very patient as producers and
we hang in there with material for a
long time and we trust that our gut is
going to sort of talk back to us
eventually maybe hopefully and
truthfully Adam called and said I love
this and I want to do this and I was
like ah like yes that's how we're gonna
do it that's how we get this story
across the transom and into the world
because we know our huge fan had been
huge fans
anyone who knows his work knows he's a
ferocious mind and he's a very political
thinker and he doesn't think that
learning and humor are mutually
exclusive so it was it was a really it
was amazing moment I mean so many people
Adam are so impressed with your work on
this movie do you feel like there was a
part of you that felt like you had
something to prove no I don't think that
I think it was more of a thing I've I
read the book and I loved it so much it
was you know it was one of those things
where I couldn't put it down
and you know I had a lot of other things
going on and it was a couple years later
that my agent asked me if you could do
anything in the world what would you do
and before I knew what I was saying I
said the big short so no this was more
of a case of I just thought this was one
of the books of our time basically I
thought this was it combines so many
things I loved it was entertaining it
was informative the characters were
incredible that I just was dying to do
it so if anything if I had been smart I
would have just said you know
let's go do another comedy or an action
film or something but it's just at that
point didn't matter and when didi and
Jeremy were open to me pursuing this it
was really exciting for me it just it's
one of the most pleasurable
scriptwriting experiences I've ever had
every day I just looked forward to it
cuz I loved it so much and I just felt
like it was a story that needed to be on
the big screen Steve you know anyone
who's talked to you or met you knows
that just what a lovely and kind of
pleasant guy you are yes yes that's true
is there is there a joy in being
unpleasant are you are you implying that
the character is unpleasant just a bit
we're not talking Foxcatcher here by the
way but we're you know but on that scale
sure yeah I I get to I get to be
somebody that I don't get to be at home
because my wife would have none of it
but I didn't find the real guy I mean I
didn't find him to be unpleasant per se
he's brusque he's very opinionated he's
he's a guy that feels comfortable in any
situation he came to set the second day
I was shooting and by the end of the day
he was giving Adam notes he was giving
me notes and they were good they were
good no so he backs it up with
intelligence and grit and gumption but
yeah it's fun it's fun to play
characters that aren't necessarily who I
am my understanding correct me if I'm
wrong all of you that Christian Bale's
character is the only one who is called
by the name of the man that he's
inspired by or so it was was your guy
Iseman is his last name right was he
upset that he that you weren't playing a
guy with his name given that you were
playing inspired by at the premiere he
came up to me and said I was he said he
was really nervous and I asked him why
and he said because I thought he said
that he thought I was going to portray
him as a complete [ __ ] and he said
cuz I'm not I'm not really that big an
[ __ ] and I said yeah you are sure and
he said I have a good sense of humor and
I said no no you don't at all Steve but
he was very relieved and I
has been speaking to him a lot in the
last few weeks basically emails be every
other day was some weird bit of press
have you seen this and I'm like Steve
I've seen it don't worry it's gonna be a
lot of press you know the funny thing
was when he was on set he we told him
don't come behind the monitor don't give
notes to the actors which are in like 30
seconds installed a TV was there behind
the monitor and so I finally went up to
him I said you know Steve you shouldn't
be and in the middle of me talking to
him he got a phone call and walked away
true the highest compliment I can pay
this movie is that I seeing it I feel
like I finally understand what happened
right how important of a goal in the
list of goals was that for you all and
how difficult was that to achieve yeah I
think early on when I talked to Dede and
Jeremy we we decided that you know the
characters are amazing but part of the
power of the book is that I a guy who
was an English major who directed the
movie stepbrothers finished the book and
actually understood the shape of the the
fraud and the collapse and that the
information and the characters almost
went hand-in-hand so we knew it was a
really unusual challenging movie in that
sense that we had this like great
cinematic side to it which were the
characters but we also have this
informational side that was kind of
crucial so that was kind of when we
talked about the idea of breaking the
fourth wall and the idea of like giving
information in conjunction I kept I
wanted to make sure if we're gonna do
this movie that I fully understood how
the collapse happened so I kept talking
to economists I kept reading books and
then I would go back to my wife for
starters who knows nothing about finance
and I would explain it to her so then
finally she said all right I get it
so then I went to my ten-year-old
daughter pearl and I would explain it to
her and she would go dad I'm so bored by
this it's all business and then one day
I explained it to her and she's like
that's kind of interesting so I knew I
had it at that point yeah I love the
fact that you and Ryan are kind of
teaming up occasionally and you're
bringing out
really funny side of him are you gonna
take the credit he's hosting SNL I don't
I I've just called my wife to have her
tape it he is he's a really funny guy
and you know I we worked together once
before and he's not known for doing
comedy but he is a supremely talented
improviser and Adam knows this probably
better than anyone he'd get on set and
it's it's a different you know there's
people who can improvise and say funny
things and come up with jokes but
there's another level of being able to
improvise within a character and and an
on point on story and Ryan does that so
beautifully and and he's always he's
always coming up with new ideas and and
new things for the strip and you gave
him carte blanche essentially for this
character
yeah our initial conversation you know I
had met with Ryan about two years ago
and I knew he was a great actor and I
knew he was also a writer and a director
so when I wrote the role the way I wrote
it breaking the fourth wall I always had
Ryan and mine for it because he's a guy
who can obviously act in a grounded way
but also has sort of that other Minds so
I simply told him I said okay you will
play this role but at any point you can
look at the camera and say whatever you
want to say and he was like yes I'm in I
mean your entire cast from Stephen Ryan
and Christian and Brad all the way down
to like max Greenfield and Billy
Magnussen as the two cocky guys in
Florida it's just such an ace cast when
you guys have been to three of you think
back to it what was the toughest role to
find the perfect person for well the
last part we cast was Vinnie
Jeremy strong who we treasure and we
know Jeremy from Selma and he's he's
become a good friend of ours and he was
desperate to be in the movie and bless
his heart he came and auditioned for a
couple of other parts that just weren't
quite right for him and then we were
gonna go different and then then the
part of any came up and I remember
calling him and saying I know I
know you've gone through heartbreak but
I'm telling you you've got to just come
back and put yourself on tape for this
part please and and he did and the
minute we saw we were like there he is
and we and at the end that character had
proved elusive or was that that casting
and it was um it was really amazing to
call and say okay it worked there's even
a crazier edge to the story which is you
know Jeremy was so disappointed he so
wanted to be in this movie and he had
read for these roles that he wasn't
quite right for us so like in the
bathtub that thing margot robbie part he
really wanted and so he went and read an
article by basically a shrink talking
about disappointment and how to deal
with disappointment in the creative
world and he read this article and said
oh my god i have to talk to this guy and
he goes to meet with a guy and it turns
out it's my shrink this is a true story
and the shrink says you know gives them
the talk about hey it's not about
results it's about your process and the
next day after Dede had pushed for him
to read for this role I was like Dede
you're totally right he's amazing for it
we gave him the role so kind of a crazy
story